foreign
let's go out to Charleston South
Carolina and talk to the one and only
and what's up Ann
hi Dr John thank you for taking my call
of course thanks for calling what's up
okay so my husband's parents divorced 50
years ago and recently
um we were told that they want to
remarry oh man do they marry other
people after the divorce
and he was raised by his mom and stepdad
he was very close to a stepdad and his
dad was in the picture but he didn't
live with him so he doesn't have a real
close relationship with his father
um and for the time that we've been
married 25 plus years his mom and dad
have had very little contact with each
other to the point that
um like like special occasions baptism
things like that his dad wouldn't even
come to if his mom was going to be there
so
um about a year ago both his step
parents passed away
spend a short amount of time from one
another
and
um
his
so now he's got two he's got a mom and a
dad that are newly widowed and
um this past Christmas they were both at
our house his mom and his dad and they
were very cordial with one another we're
talking and they both like to travel
um they're both obviously getting over
the death of a spouse and they had
stayed married to the same spouse for
almost 50 years or not quite 50 years
probably 45 years or so and
um they both got to talking of how they
wanted to travel so about two months ago
they decided to go on a little getaway
together and they told us just as
friends
yeah right just like teenagers right I
guess well and we believe them I guess I
don't know it was kind of I mean even
traveling together was kind of
kind of weak you know what maybe it'll
be good for him so
that was about eight weeks ago and then
just recently his mom told him that they
are thinking of remarrying ah baby I
love it how old are they how old are
they they're in their 70s they're in
their 70s hey y'all stay away stay out
of it
okay like like my husband's having a
hard time with it he's gonna have a hard
time with it there's no way around that
um
and there may be some complexity here
like Estate Planning and prenups and all
that kind of stuff I won't get into that
because he may have kids and she may
have other kids like that's all messy
and whatever yeah well my husband's an
only child so he doesn't even have
anyone to like
like sibling to talk about it with so I
here's here's here's how I would take
this and both my parents are in their
70s okay so I'm just speaking how I
would internalize this a that's super
weird
super weird be
maybe not the healthiest thing and
also be
when your parents are in their 70s and
they're like we're just getting Burgers
what are you gonna do right right like
what are you gonna do and so you can
try to get in the middle of this or
y'all can or he can like have a talk
it's too soon you all need to y'all are
still grieving whatever or you can just
say you know what y'all are teenagers
again just go party till the wheels fall
off like what else what's the other
option right right right and I think
he's is afraid of it not working out a
second time because obviously yeah they
didn't ask him yeah exactly he didn't
get a vote and so it probably won't work
out probably or that's kind of how we
feel it might be incredible and so so
weird so weird right it is incredibly
it's so weird yeah and even our kids are
like what like yeah so weird all you
have to do is this you have to say ew a
lot right don't say you but here's
here's the reality you and your husband
need especially your husband he had a
very clear picture of what the next 10
or 15 years are going to look like right
and that may be very different now
that's his picture to deal with not
theirs
right so I got I had this um this woman
who worked with me she's incredible I
won't use her name here because she I
haven't asked her if that's okay
um she lost her husband and
I met her new husband that they had been
remarried that she'd gotten remarried um
after her husband passed away
I was awesome
awesome and in a million years I would
not have picked this guy with her and so
I was asking about it I was like dude
this guy's amazing and but so different
than I would have imagined and right I
was talking through like you know how do
you get remarried and how do you rebuild
a life and here's what she said to me
and it it was so profound she said oh
John we're not building a life
she said I did that
I built a life and I built a home I
raised kids I've done that that part of
my life is over I now have married
somebody who's my best friend who's my
ride or die and we're gonna get old and
we're gonna get wrinkled up together and
we're gonna go to the lake every weekend
and it was such a powerful transition
for me right like oh you you and I have
very different goals relationally I'm
trying to keep my marriage together like
duct tape and bailing wire and trying to
figure out how to raise a teenager
y'all are just going to the lake baby
right it's a it was a totally different
mindset and so I'm not going to impose
it does it doesn't it doesn't lessen the
sacredness of marriage and all that it's
just different stages right yeah and so
they say hey we're gonna we're going for
it
I I mean what
I mean why not that's what I told my
husband I said it's their life they're
not telling us how to live our life so
we really can't tell them how to live
their life so if that's what they want
and if it doesn't work out that's on
them it's not on us yeah and you could
tell them hey if this thing it works out
all the way to the right or Die end we
will be so happy and if it doesn't work
out I'll be here for you you both can
call me backwards that's cool yeah yeah
yeah I think it's just I think I think
he feels like it's it's just rush like
they oh it is make no mistake no it went
from a little getaway just as friends
and now we're thinking about getting
married and he's like oh like it's it's
hardly been a year since your spouse has
passed away and when you're and and her
thing is she says she doesn't like being
unwed and that he will take very good
care of her okay
so here's the deal okay
like the the notebook and the Titanic
are over now right right I mean that
season's passed yeah and Safety and
Security and love and commonality and
ooh like all that's awesome
right it's just different it's totally
different stages and so how old are you
guys
we're in our 50s okay you you know it's
you're it's starting to accelerate
but you are because you've become aware
probably over the last five to ten years
how insanely precious minutes and hours
are
sure right if you just met it doesn't
move proportionally it's like compound
interest that pressure and that feeling
you feel like my wife told me a few
months ago oh my gosh we only have five
Spring Breaks left with our son
oh then he's gone and I was like what
you know I mean like five spring breaks
and I missed the last two traveling for
work that's over that I never I got five
left you're you're you're you're further
down the road than I am you start to see
how precious this time is when you get
to be 70 that s that that that that
accelerates in such a powerful way and
so I would your husband's gonna have to
grieve because he had a picture and that
picture is gonna be different it that
might be different because his parents
are back together it might be different
that he's got to deal with his dad that
he felt bailed on him and that may be
part of the issue yeah any number of
things but I think
the posture is y'all are crazy but good
for y'all yeah I mean what do you I mean
what do you do you think this is too
soon but it's it's your life
I want you to have as much fun as
possible in your remaining time together
I don't know right I don't know why you
would hope for anything other than that
right right right and that's what I told
him I said you know they're older they
they have all these years down the road
like a younger couple would be you know
so waiting a year or two to get married
is not really it may not be in the
courts for them so maybe that's why they
want to hurt you well and here's the
deal
none of us get a vote
unless my dad sat me down or my mom
called and sat me down and said I need
you to be very specific with me am I
making the worst mistake of my life and
even then I would probably say I can't
tell you that if you want to be with
somebody and this is the dude for the
for the last
10 or 15 years of your life yeah and
statistically they're already playing on
house money right now right right and so
who knows what tomorrow brings once you
are in your mid 70s and on you're
playing on house money and so let's have
as much fun and joy and love as possible
yeah right right good advice thank you
I will pass it on to him okay good luck
with that good luck with that I know
it's not I know it's not going to be
easy
um and I'll just say this I'm smiling
this whole call it's it's
I I just it brings me joy it just does
there's so much heartache and so much
um
I I can't wrap my head around losing
somebody that you were with for 50 years
50 years I can't wrap my head around
that and so the idea that two people
found each other albeit pretty quickly
found each other and we're like are you
in I'm in let's just see how much gas is
left in this in this old truck I that
just brings me joy that makes me smile
and again there's going to be a state
things to figure out there's going to be
Insurance things to figure out there's
gonna be all that stuff that's that's
all a pain in the butt and you can't
skip those steps you gotta deal with
those things
but just at its core
I mean what else are you gonna do you're
gonna shut down your 75 year old mom and
be like no
you call me before you date again no man
you're gonna you're gonna say
knock your lights out guys you all have
a good time and we'll be there at the
wedding and uh maybe you and your dad
have to have a hard conversation that's
fine or maybe just not maybe just not
thanks for the calling and you're
awesome